uh sure so i forgot
it is it's your turn now or mine uh it
it's yours
it's mine i see all right so uh
uh i guess we can start now uh so hello
everyone
uh welcome back from the break it's my
pleasure to introduce the next uh
talk on networks and graphical models uh
it's a theme that is uh co-rounded by
christian
and ankur and krishna will give a talk
not just i decided to give the mit side
not quite their fair share but a little
bit at least
so i mean just like mike and kostic were
working very much together
anka and i did this very much together
so i
felt i should give him some of this
creature
um
oh wow this is not doesn't want
to proceed
let me
is it maybe better to share the screen
and not
app
well as long as you don't have any
confidential information in your screen
that could work it seems not to work
you know i had a few embarrassing
accidents when i tried to shut the
screen so
i don't do that anymore but uh
so let me try it again is
am i still sharing the screen or not uh
no you are not showing the screen
okay
okay okay yeah good okay
so this is uh networks and graphical
models theme you see
our team it's a nice mixture of mit
and berkeley a lot of us have already
worked together and many of us have
worked on both sides
so i will talk about the network park
and then uncle will talk a little bit
about graphical models
um so and uh i thought i could even
though some of you might have seen graph
fonts
uh a lot of you might have seen it in
the context of graph limits i thought i
will show how graph phones are used
for uh modeling network estimation
recommendation
things and then get to some of the
algorithmic questions which are there
so um as motivations just
think about what is so the whole thing
started by us thinking what's the
correct notion of a limit of a large
sparse network um and but very much
related
is actually how we model large parts
networks and how do we
recommendation systems is one
possibility
another one recently uh done by some
people at stanford
is a question can you do
information dissemination on networks
the
kkt model and things like that so um
just to these three questions so if you
look at many networks we see in the
world
they look evenly similar right so can we
find a way
of defining a limit which makes
similar networks the same in the limit
so is linked
and facebook the same or not and so we
came up with the notion of graph limits
which led to the notion of a graph
and i won't assume you know what it is
so i will
tell it to you in a little while okay
the other question
is okay you want to model large network
so let's
assume you have a single snapshot of
facebook today
and you want to learn a network model
and then predict
how the network will look when it's
double as large
and it turns out again the answer is a
graph one so you can
estimate assuming that you have this
non-parametric model of a graph and we
can learn the generating platform
and once you have learned it you can
generate new networks maybe larger to
see how they look in the future
or smaller because you want to test some
algorithm which you
can't test on the huge network
and finally there's a question of matrix
completion
or estimation problems we sort of all
know it from facts
netflix mike talked about it and they're
actually interesting question
i think in the intersection of our semen
has seen
but i will not go into these here
so again it turns out that you can have
an underlying graph on which
uh generates its rankings and if it's
uh finite rank you can very efficiently
estimate
uh the missing entries in this matrix uh
which is
work with some of the people uh devry is
in part of the c so um
so what is the graph okay so the short
answer if you sort of don't want to do
mass
well a little bit of mass it's a
function of two variables
and this describes the limit of a
sequence of graphs that's how we
invented it
but actually it also describes a
non-parametric model for random graphs
or more generally a probability
distribution over recommendations
so i give you two definitions the first
one will work
for the limits and the model so
a graph one is just a function defined
over a probability space
so it has two variables so therefore we
have here omega cross omega
um and it should be integral form to
make it sort of treated
and if you go to the recommendation
system you make it a little bit more
general
so you don't have just one feature so
think of it i mean if we want to go to
network modeling for example
you should think of the features as
features describing your users
and then this function will tell you
about the affinity between different
users
and in the second setting you have
actually two different spaces because
there's no reason that people rating
items
and items to be rated should have the
same feature set
so you have two possible probability
spaces and then the graph one is a
function which is not symmetric anymore
and it doesn't map into r plus but it
maps in general into a probability
distribution on one up to k
k is two then it's just one probability
so
it's a subset here but in general it's
modern
okay and i will first walk you through
an application
um which actually has found application
in a little startup
i can't tell you too much about the
startup and luckily i don't know too
much about
because i'm bad in keeping secrets so
that ask my collaborators how this
startup works
so you have the following problem you
have
um ratings amazon
hulu netflix and you have this matrix
and you observe a very sparse matrix and
now you want to fill in
this matrix and see will this little
girl
like okay and you want to put some stars
there
related is network completion okay so
you have
some network on linkedin
and you want to sort of guess should i
introduce these two people to each other
or not
so you want to predict would they
connect to each other or do i waste my
advertising dollars connecting people
which don't want to connect any
um you can also have weighted networks
so you can send emails i used to work at
microsoft so that's why you have the
outlook sign here
um you can do recommendations uh in of
whatever way i mean most of our networks
in the real world
are awaited and i mean even if you think
about
transmitting covet right it depends how
often i see somebody so
for your networks you really have a
frequency of interactions
you observe some of them and you might
want to fill in the others
so the framework is that of matrix
completion
and in the background we think that this
was generated by
let's say this is the movie so this
movie has some features
and this row which is the users has some
features as well
and then given these features there will
be some probability distribution
on ratings and you would like to learn
the probability distribution from what
you see here
and then fill this in okay so
how do we usually do that well usually
we do collaborative filtering so what we
do is we look at the movies
you rate we look at the movie's irate
and then we will give we will claim that
the two of us are similar if we give
similar ratings to movies we both have
rated
or short if we like similar movies
now the problem is that if you have a
very sparse
observation there will be no overlap so
what do you do well
so our idea was we do expanding this
actually came from some
graph estimation algorithms out of
a princeton group which used this idea
first so we applying it here to the
recommendations
um they used it to actually estimate an
underlying graph on
we actually avoid estimating the graph
fund which is a good thing i will
explain to you in a little more
so what do you do well we look at the
movies rated by this little girl and
then we look who rates this movie
and so on so if you want we look at the
network neighborhood
of this girl in the bipartite graph
of rated movies and people
we go on and on and on and eventually
it's this side is square root of n by
the birthday paradox you get
common ratings and now you can start to
compare things
okay and there are many ways to compare
uh
we will compare the product of the
ratings along the path but there's just
some way
the main point is that you compare these
network networks
and it turns out this just works nicely
okay
let me give you another so it's nicely
in the sense that if i have finite rank
you can see i only need a finite number
of observed observations per row
so roughly proportional to the rank
squared so if the rank is
fine rank is roughly the dimensions of
the feature space so if that is five
then you would need 25 entries per
per row so once i've rated 25 movies
you don't care that there are millions
of movies i only have to rank
sort of uh on description okay
so now let's switch to to network
modeling so that is
originally goes back to the
social science starch community uh
bola basians and riordan invented the
model i'm
giving you here um so how does this
model work well you have some feature
space
and again you have the graph one which
is the function of this
feature space squared and some
distribution and now you
choose for each of your users some
feature according to some probability
distribution on the feature space
and then you connect inj with
probability w
well if you wanted sparse you might want
to sparse it down and if w want
you want w to represent power loss maybe
w
is really unbounded so you better take a
minimum of one in this
product here okay and then you output
this object
and now given a single sample you would
like to estimate this graph
so this is slightly different from usual
estimation where we have many samples
here we have one sample if you want it's
very much related to dependent samples
because you have different
pieces of this graph but they're not
really independent
so it's an example of dependent samples
which is one of the themes we want to
look at
um there are some identifiability issues
there's technically well understood
i mean since you learned about couplings
and wasserstein distance essentially
if you can couple your probability
spaces such that the two graphs become
the same
then they should be considered identical
and up to that equivalent class
you can sort of so you output just one
graph form but you're well aware that
there could be many others representing
the same object and we avoided that in
the recommendation
system um we just used that the
underlying model
was represented by such an object
essentially what we did is we replaced
the
hidden latent features by the observed
feature of the network neighborhood
and that actually made the whole thing
work
okay so how would we do this estimation
i
well i have a little bit time for ankur
so assume we have this one sample
the basic idea in this is we want to
approximate w
by the best block model approximation to
the adjacency matrix
okay so you observe your network you
average
over little blocks okay
so this is your sum over so this is
block
i well this is not block pi of i and you
sum over all i in that block so you
sum over all i j in a given block and
then you minimize all the best possible
alignment with blocks
and then you claim well this guy should
be almost something like a low frequency
estimate of your adjacency matrix
and your output set okay
so right if you want a graph on your
outwards a piecewise function which is
constants you sort of
think of a little checkerboard with
widths one over k one over k squares and
then you put these entries in there so
if you really want to output the
function
um good and so this works
and then there's sort of a question
which
hints at something we will really want
to analyze in this
part which is differential prices okay
so we all know that
releasing statistical information about
people
is difficult if you want to respect
their privacy
and it certainly becomes difficult if
you're on netflix right so your
links on facebook really say a lot about
you and you might say well just
de-anonymize my animal nice sorry
and the problem is it actually can
easily be undone
okay so it doesn't have that you don't
know who i am because you have side
information it's easy to learn who i
am and so what's the principle way to do
that it's differential privacy um
and our claim is that you can actually
do that let me just jump over that
because i don't want to
walk you through what so here is
first the summary of my view of graph
graphs and recommendation systems
i haven't talked to you about that but
essentially okay a graph has a vertex
set and a matrix
and then the graph one is a continuum it
has
a continuous feature space and a
function of two variables
then you can use that to model graphs
and then you can actually use graph
estimation to get back here
and the recommendation system is similar
now that you you have two feature spaces
you have a probability distribution
valued graph on
you get a rating matrix and then you use
matrix completion
so you never actually solve this problem
which means you also avoid the problem
of identifiability so i think that's how
our approach differs from that of the
princeton group
they really tried to estimate an
underlying
graph formula in their case stochastic
block model whereas we
avoid it so let me finish with a few
open problems
sorry um
so a lot is known about the statistical
deficiencies i mean like slower bounds
and things like that
we know very little about how to do
efficiently do graph an estimate you
might have seen i had some some overall
permutations that
obviously screams exponential time if
you
glanced what i said for differential
privacy we use the exponential algorithm
again that
smells like exponential time so maybe
actually we can't do it so
this is an interesting question which
really deserves
explorations there's also a well-known
relationship between differential
privacy and robustness
so can we explore that in the context of
networks
okay and then the question is
use sort of the underlying graphone
assumption to design efficient
algorithms so this is for example an
example where people showed you might
have heard of the
independent cast card model you want to
estimate where you should see the
information in the network
and they sort of it's mp heart there's
some approximation algorithms which are
complicated to implicate i actually did
some of those myself
but um it turns out that if you have an
underlying
hidden graph on random seeds
just are all you need so this is sort of
work out of stanford i don't think it's
published yet but it sort of
involves economists so accept it to be
published in five to ten years
so with that i will hand it over to
uncle
great let me just start sharing my
screen
can you see my screen
not yet it says like started screen
shading
double click to enter full screen mode
it says
boy let me just retry it
all right okay so um yeah thanks for um
giving me a few minutes to talk about
this so i don't have much time to tell
you too much about graphical models
but you know what i hope to do is just
give you an idea about some interesting
vignettes
you know i think when you talk about
graphical models these are things that
many of you will have seen before and
there's this belief that they've been
you know studied since
antiquity so there must not be you know
open algorithmic or statistical problems
but i want to try and disabuse you of
that idea in this talk and show you
at least one example where there's some
pretty wide gaps in our understanding
and we've only made it a little ways
since then so let's start off with some
basic notions so imagine you have a high
dimensional gaussian
another problem that's been studied
since antiquity
now to put this in the language of
graphical models what we really care
about is the inverse of the covariance
matrix which is usually called the
precision matrix that's
really the main character and what i'm
going to be telling you about so that's
theta
and we'll be interested in cases where
theta is sparse
because actually the reason that theta
is natural is because it captures
the important conditional independent
structure so the markov structure
in the sense of a graphical model so
what you can do is you can take these
kinds of high dimensional distributions
and you can associate a graph with them
so you can create if it's an n
dimensional gaussian
a graph on n nodes where you put an edge
if and only if the corresponding entry
in the precision matrix is
non-zero and the important thing is that
the graph really captures the
conditional independence aspects of this
model
because two nodes turn out to be
independent conditioned on a separator
if and only if that separator blocks all
paths in a graph theoretic sense
that any path from i to j must pass
through
the set x u which you're conditioning on
so you know one of the questions that
you know i think um
it is surprisingly pretty open it's
something that you would have actually
thought was closed
was can you learn gaussian graphical
models from very few samples
so the truth is that ggm's show up in
all kinds of applications particularly
in science and social sciences but one
of the reasons we care about them is
because
in a lot of those settings we have very
few samples but we have tons of
variables
so we think of them as somehow the
canonical type of graph structure that
that we can learn when we're in those
settings so just to give you an example
of this this is
a network taken from a pretty recent
paper
which is inferring something about the
genetic network
underlying certain types of cancer and
the way that they do this
is using gaussian graphical models as a
primitive so trying to learn the
precision matrix
and creating a graph based on whatever
they've learned
and the key point is that they have very
few samples so you hope to learn these
kinds of things and
a number of samples that's logarithmic
in the number of nodes that you're
trying to fit an interesting model
to so you know these types of things are
actually extremely well studied there's
um you know very famous paper of
friedman hasty and tipsurani
which uses the graphical lasso so it
uses a lot of ideas from
you know compressed sensing like lasso
and adapts them to gaussian graphical
models
but when i what i want to convince you
of is that they're actually hidden
assumptions
that govern you know when these things
work which maybe it makes sense to take
a more sober look and ask whether they
are or not satisfied
so there are also approaches like the
climb estimator that you know is in some
sense related to graphical lasso with a
little bit incomparable guarantees
but the thing that i want to highlight
is there's this recent work of misra
vufrey and lokov
which you know really revisited this
problem and you know asked
what is the right information theoretic
dependence because
there's a key parameter that i didn't
talk about which really governs the
non-degeneracy of the model
so i mentioned that we care about theta
as being sparse
right now you can't hope to learn which
entries in theta are zero or non-zero if
the entries are too close to zero
so the natural thing is to somehow
assume that the entries that are
non-zero are noticeably non-zero but you
have to be very careful with the right
normalization
it turns out that the right information
theoretic bound is to look at the
absolute value of the off-diagonal entry
and compare it to the geometric average
of the diagonal entries
but this has a nice interpretation in
terms of you know the covariances and
the variances of these things
see it turns out that a lot of the
assumptions which are fine in compressed
sensing things like the restricted
isometry property
that you know every set of you know 2k
columns of your matrix acts like an
isometry are really not
super relevant in gaussian graphical
models because you do expect
to have some variables that are very
strongly dependent on each other
because that's actually the structure
that you're trying to fit in a lot of
these scientific and social science
applications
and it's not always reasonable to assume
that a variable's conditional variance
for any condition on
everything else in the network is pretty
large compared to its variance to begin
with
a lot of these you know natural models
have very strong dependencies and they
become
ill-conditioned very quickly so the
surprise is that even when these things
are
you know ill-conditioned you just need
this non-degeneracy parameter kappa
to be bounded away from zero and then
information theoretically you can
actually learn with a logarithmic number
of samples
where d here is the sparsity of each of
the columns of your
matrix or rows and just to give you a
concrete example of you know something
simple that you can wrap your heads
around which
you know is a very simple gaussian
graphical model but has very strong
dependencies
is imagine you do something like a
gaussian random walk on a line
if you take the node at the very end
that has a giant variance its variance
is
n but the conditional variance is tiny
because if you tell me my leftmost
neighbor
then my conditional variance is one so
it's a very ill-conditioned model
and there are all kinds of things like
this that exhibit these strong
dependencies
so this question is believe it or not
basically wide open we have some
you know partial work on it but this is
really an invitation to think about
these kinds of issues
so for something called walk-summable
gaussian graphical models that contain
gaussian-free fields and mtp2
we used a lot of ideas from laplacian
solvers
to design polynomial time algorithms
with logarithmic sample complexity
but i think this is also indicative of
how some of these themes are very
interconnected right
because for some of these things it
might just be that there are fundamental
computational versus
statistical tradeoffs it turns out that
when you talk about the right
information theoretic bounds the key
primitives that show up are things like
sparse linear regression
without the restricted isometric
property but we don't know a reduction
the other direction so are these types
of ggm's related
to the conjectural computational reverse
statistical trade-offs there
and you know looking outwards i think
for a lot of these different graphical
models problems
there are a lot of assumptions that
people make that you know govern the
algorithms that they want to analyze
that
maybe don't hold in a lot of settings so
i think you know one of the major things
that
many of us would like to do is revisit
some of these things and
understand whether there's scope for
designing more exciting algorithms
so i'll stop there and uh christian and
i are happy to take any questions you
guys might have
right christian and uncle thank you
we have one minute for questions
uh
speak now or forever hold your peace
yeah i i do have some questions but uh
uh
i think i would just uh uh you know for
the sake of
uh you know keeping things on schedule i
will just uh
ping you guys directly so
thank you again and
the next talk will be by michael
and this will be about algorithms
predictions
go ahead michael okay are you seeing the
front slide okay i see the front slide
and
it was your photo uh can you go to the
next slide just to double check
yeah perfect okay uh good
so i'll be talking about algorithms with
predictions this is part of the
machine learning for algorithms group
and
uh part of what we're doing and what
i'll be talking about today is using
how we might use machine learning to
improve the performance of classical
algorithms
the ideas to get the best of both worlds
you know some
want correctness that we expect from our
traditional algorithms but also
adaptivity you know you can think of it
as a beyond worst case analysis type
analysis
which i will be describing uh so
again the the traditional algorithms are
based on worst case analysis
and of course that's been great it's
what's been given all us three people
jobs for decades
but it isn't everything and uh as
many of us know we've been parts of the
theory community have definitely been
trying to go
beyond worst-case analysis the phrase
um popularized i think by tim rufgarden
um uh and established by tim roughgarden
and of course there's been that
you know sort of all along we've looked
at things like random or perturbed or
limited inputs or approximation
algorithms
and now we want to see how machine
learning can possibly give us more
all right so machine learning can be
used to give predictions
and then so the question is is if we
assume that we are getting some sort of
good predictions
not perfect predictions but good
predictions can we do
better results than just using our
worst-case algorithms
and of course this leads the question of
how can we be
safe or what should we be doing in case
the predictions are bad
so we'd like provable statements of the
form that you know if my predictions are
this good
my algorithm's performance will
correspondingly be good
and we call this sort of framework
algorithms with predictions or
or sometimes learning augmented
algorithms
all right so here's a quick outline um
piotr tells me i'm overly ambitious and
there's no way i'll finish everything
and he's probably right so i may leave
off some stuff at the end but we'll
we'll see what i can get through
in the half hour um
so let's start with a simple example of
search right so we've got an array of
integers and we've got a query
we need to find it in the array so we
can just do binary search
start in the middle and and there we go
and we find
the element
an alternative if we have a prediction
is
start with the predicted place and then
use sort of a
doubling binary search look one to the
left then two to the left and four to
the left
until we find an interval where it
appears and then we can use
sort of a binary search once we find the
actual interval
that the element appears in but the idea
is to use a prediction to help start us
on our search all right so binary search
is
order login and what you can
see or it's a pretty simple analysis
this based search
is order log of whatever your prediction
error error is
right and here i'm not counting whatever